MARY PILON: My
name is Mary Pilon.
I'm the author of "The
Monopolist," which
just came out in February.
I previously worked
as a sports reporter
at "The New York Times"
and before that wrote
about money and Wall Street
at "The Wall Street Journal."
So mostly now, I write
about business, sports,
kind the intersection of all.
But also along the
way, I've learned a lot
about board games, which is what
I'm here to talk to you guys
about today.
So this is Monopoly.
Now, most people are very
familiar with the game.
It's made by Parker
Brothers, which
in 1991 was acquired by Hasbro.
This is the Monopoly board.
You guys have probably
all played on it.
There's Mr. monopoly, the
iconic little mustachioed
man with the
monocle and top hat,
the little red
houses, green hotels.
There are a lot of jokes in
the game industry about Parker
Brothers actually being
one of the biggest home
manufactures, hahaha.
And the story for
years was that the game
was invented by this
man, Charles Darrow,
who, during the darkest hours
of the Great Depression,
he was down on his luck.
He was unemployed.
And he goes into
his basement, and he
creates Monopoly to remind
his family of better times.
He puts these Atlantic
City properties on it
because that is where
they had vacationed.
He sells the game
to Parker Brothers.
Here's a copy of his patent.
If you look at, it's from 1935.
It looks a lot like
the Monopoly game
that we play today in 2015.
You can see the art is on there,
the properties, everything.
A version of this story about
Darrow inventing the game
and selling it to
Parker Brothers
is still on versions
of Hasbro's website.
Some people believe
that Darrow himself
was the inspiration for the
Mr. Monopoly character, which
you see up there.
Only problem with that story
is it's, like, not true.
The Darrow Cinderella story,
which is still told today,
often, actually, it turns out
Monopoly had a history long
before that started
with a woman in 1904.
This a Elizabeth J. Magie,
or Lizzie Magie, as she's
often known.
She created a game that was
called The Landord's Game, soon
thereafter called The Monopoly
Game but its early players
in 1904, long before Parker
Brothers, long before Darrow.
So who was she?
It turns out, Lizzie Magie was
a really interesting woman.
This is a copy of her patent
she had received in 1893
for this typewriter gadget.
She was a stenographer.
She was a writer.
She was a poet.
She had appeared in some
theater productions.
And then this news
clipping I love.
She was a really
outspoken feminist.
She had done this thing.
It was around the
turn of the century.
She called it the
slave girl stunt.
And basically what she did is
she put herself up for auction
to the highest bidder
as a protest against how
women were paid at the time.
And she likened how women
were treated to wage slavery.
And it got a lot of
attention around the country.
This was one of
many news clippings.
So one of the questions I
had in researching her was,
how did a women like
this come about?
I mean, this is a century ago.
And she would be pretty
outspoken by today's standards
but certainly by
then, that times.
So, her father was James Magie.
Now, James Magie was not just
an influential newspaper owner
of the time.
He was around for the early
days the Republican Party.
This is a picture of him.
He had traveled with none
other than Abraham Lincoln
during the
Lincoln-Douglas debates.
So he infuses a lot of these
values into his daughter.
She this is a template from
one of her poetry books.
And one of the things he
passes on to his daughter
is this book, "Progress and
Poverty" by Henry George.
So most people today don't
know who Henry George was.
Actually, some
Georges have shown up
to some of the book
events I've done,
which has been really fun.
Henry George-- I'm not going
to totally geek out on this,
but he believed in
single tax theory.
That's this idea that if
we tax land and only land,
the middle class
has a better shot.
And there are all of
these incredible news
accounts of him
packing out these halls
as a public speaker.
And he ran for mayor of
New York City, actually,
and came in second behind
a Tammany Hall candidate
but ahead of this
Teddy Roosevelt guy.
So he wasn't some wingnut
of his time period.
I mean, people were
really into him.
And I kind of think
of him politically
as very much a reaction to the
Carnegies, the Rockefellers,
this amount of wealth
that was being created
at the turn of the century
that this country hadn't
seen before.
And there's a lot of
questioning about how
this should be distributed.
And it's really fun to
read some of this stuff.
I read "Progress and Poverty."
And also, the single
taxers sometimes
called themselves
anti-monopolists.
And a lot of what
they're talking about
could be ripped
from the headlines
today about income inequality,
wage distribution, things
like that.
So anyway, this is her patent
for The Landlord's Game.
She applies in 1903.
She receives it in 1904.
And you can see, if
you look at it closely,
there's some things that you'd
recognize from a Monopoly
board.
So she has Go To Jail on there.
She has Public Park.
The Georges were very
concerned with public land
and how it was used
and natural resources.
But obviously cars weren't
as big of a deal in 1904,
so hers does not
have cars on it.
So after she patents it,
this game goes viral,
but like
turn-of-the-century style.
And it becomes a favorite
among left-wing intellectuals,
but especially in the Northeast.
So [INAUDIBLE] of Rex Tugwell.
Rex Tugwell was an
economist at Colombia.
He later joined
FDR's brain trust.
He played the game.
In the center you
have Ernest Angell,
who was a national
chairman for the ACLU.
He had played it
here in New York,
I believe in the late
'20s, early '30s.
If there are any New Yorker
fans or sports journalism fans,
Roger Angell is his son.
Scott Bearing plays it.
And Scott Nearing was
involved in a very famous
academic freedom
case at Wharton.
He plays it there.
And he's also, later
in life, considered
to be one of the founders
of the Green movement.
And it's played heavily
in Arden, Delaware, which
is this single-tax colony.
It was a big summer
hangout for these people.
The game was very popular.
And one of the people who hung
out in Arden, Delaware, a lot
was Upton Sinclair.
And this is like
a total tangent,
but there's an amazing sex
scandal involving Upton
Sinclair at Arden, Delaware.
And his cabin there was called
The Jungalow, clearly an homage
to "The Jungle."
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, so this is kind
of like a freewheeling--
I don't know if I'd
call them hippies,
because it predates that,
but kind of a freewheeling
group of folks.
So anyway, in 1924 Lizzie
renews her patent for the game.
And it's unclear how aware
she was of how this game was
being embraced and played.
And people, when they
made their own games,
they would localize it.
So there were New York games.
They were Boston games.
There were Philly games.
And one group that
really embraces it
are the Quakers
of Atlantic City.
This is a picture of a
Quaker Monopoly night, which
was very common at the time.
And they make the board
like Atlantic City,
because that's where they live.
That's the community they know.
And they make some key
changes to Monopoly
to make it more like the
game that we know today.
So for example, in addition to
the Atlantic City properties,
they put fixed
prices on the board.
A realtor, actually, in
Atlantic City does that.
They also originality
in Monopoly,
in The Landlord's Game,
there's a lot more auctioning
with the game.
So the noise of that
bothers the Quakers.
Silence is a tenet
of their faith.
So they decide, because
they're playing with children,
they want to make it
simpler, to get rid of that.
So now there's the fixed prices.
What most people don't
realize-- how most people play
Monopoly wrong is another
conversation we can get
into later, but usually
when you land on a property,
if you don't want to purchase
it, you put it up for auction.
That's actually the rule.
But there was a
lot more of that.
And then they also
corporate hotels.
Around the Great
Depression, Atlantic City,
if anybody's watched
Boardwalk Empire knows,
is was kind of the
place to be in the '20s.
But during the Great Depression,
a lot of these big hotels
were vacant.
And some of the Quaker teachers
who were playing Monopoly
were staying in these
now-vacant hotels.
So they incorporate
those into the game.
So one of players who plays the
Atlantic City Quaker version
of the game is Charles Todd.
And this is a copy of
the Charles Todd board.
And as you look at this compared
with The Landlord's Game,
you're noticing that it
looks more and more and more
like Monopoly today.
It has the Atlantic
City properties.
Some of the colors
are even the same.
So Charles Todd plays
this game, and he
runs into two old friends
on the street, the Darrows.
And he had gone to
school with Ester Darrow.
And he and his wife, Olive,
invite the Darrows over
for dinner and a Monopoly night.
They say, come over.
It'll be great.
We're going to play this game.
So the Darrows and the
Todds live in Philadelphia.
And they play this game.
And they have a great time.
And Darrow asks
Todd, hey, would you
mind typing up the rules
for the game for me?
And Todd thinks this
is a little strange,
because imagine if
somebody asks you
for the rules for checkers
or chess or something
that had just been
kind of around.
But his secretary
does it nonetheless.
And Todd teaches
Darrow the game.
And let's cut to Parker
Brothers for a minute.
Parker Brothers in
the 1930s was a firm
on the brink of destruction.
It was a family-owned
firm that George Parker
had started as a teenager
in the 1800s, late 1880s,
if you want to be exact.
And he is now an old man.
You can see him there
sitting at his desk.
And the balance
sheet is a disaster.
They need a hit.
They need it quick.
And his son-in-law,
Robert Barton,
who's second from
the left there,
had just taken over the firm.
And he was a lawyer by training.
He had no game marketing
experience, anything like that.
So Barton, through his wife,
hears about this Monopoly game,
which Darrow is selling
at Wannamaker's.
This is a picture
of Wannamaker's.
Actually, if you
go to Philadelphia,
you can still go there.
I think it's a Macy's.
I'm not 110% sure.
I'm getting some good nods.
And side note on
Wannamaker's, that's actually
where the film "Mannequin"
was shot, which I thought
was amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
So Darrow and Barton
strike up this deal.
They meet in the
Flatiron Building,
which is where the
Parker showroom was.
And this is a picture of Barton.
It's a terrible photo
in terms of quality,
but he's much older
in that image.
And he buys Darrow's
game for, we believe,
$7,000 plus residuals.
And Monopoly becomes
this blockbuster hit.
And I can't really stress enough
how no commercially sold game
had sold like Monopoly
had, let alone
during the Great Depression.
And the thinking of the
game industry at the time
was, nobody's going to
want to play a real estate
game or a finance game.
It's too complicated.
It's too wonky.
And they're certainly not going
to want to play it at a time
when nobody has either
of those things.
And the Darrow story becomes a
big part of the marketing tale,
that this game actually came
from an unemployed guy himself.
He's just like you.
And they used this
to try and sell
another game called
Bulls and Bears.
And there's an
image of that there.
And game designers
weren't really-- even now,
it wasn't like being
the author of a book
or the star of a film.
These were people that weren't
incorporating marketing.
And Darrow, I think of, was
kind of one of the first people
to do that.
And Parker can't make
these sets fast enough.
So they need tokens.
Now, when the Quakers were
playing and early folk players,
they used earrings, buttons,
whatever was around.
But Parker Brothers calls
on Daoust Manufacturing,
which was this
Chicago-based company that
made Crackerjack prizes.
And the tokens-- a lot
of people have asked
me about like, what
does the top hat mean?
What does the dog mean?
And the truth is, as
far as we can tell,
they were kind of
an afterthought.
These are some of
the early tokens.
And you can notice that
some have a little loop.
That's because Daoust
made them as charms, often
for charm bracelets, and like
little different tchotchkes.
So some of them, the molds
we believe were recycled.
So for example, the iron, they
had made tokens for a flatiron
company in Chicago.
And if you bought an iron, you
would get one of these, too.
So they were kind
of an accident.
But it's not long
before Parker and Barton
realize that they
have a problem, which
is that Darrow didn't
actually invent the game.
This thing was around
for 30 years before.
And they start hearing
from people saying,
we have played this before.
And so Barton writes
to Darrow and says,
would you mind writing
up a history of the game
and your invention of it?
And Darrow-- and
this letter exchange
is in the book--
kind of waffles.
And he doesn't sign an
affidavit saying he invented it.
And he doesn't give a
narrative or anything
about Charles Todd or having
learned the game before.
And other people had tried
to sell the game on their own
before.
So this is Dan
Layman's Finance Game.
Dan Layman had also played
the game as a Quaker game.
You can see that it's very
similar with Community
Chest, a lot of the properties.
And he had sold it.
So Parker Brothers, once they
realized that this game wasn't
invented by Darrow,
goes about acquiring
all these other games.
So there's finance.
They had to meet
with Dan Layman.
There's a game called Easy Money
that Milton Bradley is making.
They get this kind of the
bizarre licensing agreement
there.
A gentlemen in Texas had
made a game called Inflation,
and this game was
out quite a bit.
But the Darrow creation
story perpetuated.
And by now, the train
had left the station.
It was everywhere.
But Lizzie, she's pissed.
So this is an
interview from 1936.
This would have been kind of
at the height of the Monopoly
craze, right after Darrow
and the game were booming.
So she gives this interview with
the "Washington Evening Star."
You can see her there.
She's now an elderly woman
with gray hair and a bun.
She's holding up her boards
and the Monopoly board.
And if you read this, it says,
"but not for Ms. Phillips."
She had gotten married by then.
"It is understood she
received $500 for her patent,
and she gets no royalties.
Probably, if one counts lawyers,
printers, and patent office
fees used up in
developing it, the game
has cost her more than
she made from it."
So in the end, the inventor
probably got nothing
or, according to
this, maybe lost.
So why did the patent office
grant the Parker-Darrow group
its patent when Magie to had
two similar ones before it?
We don't know.
Usually when you go and research
patent history, which is really
geeky stuff, there's
a thing called
the patent wrapper, which is
the information around a patent,
a lot of documents.
And the Monopoly,
the 1935 patent
that I showed you,
that patent wrapper has
been missing for, I believe,
at least 30 or 40 years.
So as a researcher, you just hit
this wall, and you're like, ah,
we'll never know!
So Magie and Darrow die.
This is Darrow's obituary in
the "New York Times" hailing him
as an All-American hero
who had created this game.
Lizzie Magie's obituary, you
have to look a lot harder for.
It's tiny.
It makes absolutely no
mention of Landlord's Game
or Monopoly or
anything like that.
And for a long time, this
was all lost to history.
So how do we know any of this?
We know this
totally by accident.
And it is because of
this guy, Ralph Anspach.
He was an economist living in
Berkeley in the early 1970s.
He was a teacher as well.
And he made a game
called Anti-Monopoly,
which, as its name implies,
is the opposite of Monopoly.
And I think of it very much as
an homage to the early '70s,
because-- I don't even
know how to describe it.
Instead of getting
total control of things,
you're breaking them apart.
And lawyers are the hero
of the game. [LAUGHTER]
So it's very much like an
homage to like Nader's Raiders
and like public
interest law at a time
when that was pretty hot.
And Ralph was very concerned
with the OPEC oil cartels
and the monopolies of his time.
And this was obviously a
moment in American history
of high cynicism.
So it's not surprising
that his game took off.
And then these
are some drawings.
He and his two sons
kind of create this game
as a monopoly backwards.
And it takes off.
There's actually a really great
line in Patty Hearst's memoir
where she buys her dad
a copy of the game,
which, if you know anything
about the Hearst family,
is juicy.
So it's a countercultural hit.
But he hears from
Parker Brothers' lawyers
really quickly saying, you
can't make Anti-Monopoly.
But instead of
Ralph backing off--
and it turns out that
Parker Brothers at this time
was reaching out to a lot of
people making spinoff games.
So there was a Spaceopoly
that received basically
a Cease and Desist.
And also, I thought
this was awesome.
There was a priest making
a game called Theopoly,
who also heard from
Parker Brothers
and immediately backed down.
But Ralph takes
a different tack.
And he decides to fight it.
And this kicks off a 10-year
long legal battle over Monopoly
versus Anti-Monopoly.
And in the process of
researching his case,
and as the case
gets more attention,
he starts to unravel the
early history of the game.
And he becomes a
detective obsessed
with telling the true story.
And he starts to travel
and track down as many
of these early
players, people who
had played the game before
1935, as he possibly can.
And Lizzie Magie at
this point is long dead.
So he finds her patent.
But he knows that a lot
of his fate in court
hinges on connecting the
dots between that 1904
patent and the game that
Parker Brothers put out
in the mid-1930s.
So he finds some of
these original players.
This is Dan Layman, who had made
Finance, who is now a retired
guy living in Pasadena.
And he finds Charles Todd.
He finds all these
people and gets
them to do sworn depositions.
And this looks like notes
from like organic chemistry,
but it's actually Ralph's notes
from trying to piece together
some of these Quaker lineages
and who is related to who,
who is married to who,
who had played the game.
And a lot of these players--
you have to remember,
this is like 30
years of history,
so the Quakers-- and this
is them later testifying.
They're obviously older now.
They didn't know where the
game had come from, either,
because they had just played it.
So by the time Todd
and these other people
were playing the
game, they didn't
know who Lizzie Magie was.
They weren't friends with her.
They didn't know.
It had kind of
spread organically.
So he has to reverse
engineer the whole story.
So one of things that he
talks to Charles Todd about
is Marvin Gardens.
Now remember, Charles Todd
is not from Atlantic City.
He's from Philadelphia.
He just learned it from
a friend who had played
that version of the game.
So if you go to Atlantic City,
Marvin Gardens is spelled with
an "-en," because it's
a combination of Margate
and Ventnor.
So that's on the
Atlantic City board,
because the people
in Atlantic City
know how to spell the
neighborhood right.
But Todd is not from there.
So he makes an error.
He spells it with an "-in."
So that's Charles Todd's
board, Marvin Gardens-- oops.
He made a spelling error.
He's a Philadelphia guy.
Now, one of the key
things in copycat cases
that lawyers and courts look at
is whether you copy an error.
Because what are
the odds that you're
going to make the
exact same error twice.
So the Darrow board has
Marvin with an "-in."
Da-da-daa!
And Charles Todd
later jokes that he
believes this is one of the
most repeated spelling errors
in history.
Because every Monopoly
board from 1935 on
has his spelling error.
One of the other things that
comes up in the Anspach case
are the color groupings.
And this is an earlier
Monopoly board.
Actually, this was in
really beautiful shape.
And a collector had
emailed me this photo.
He had found it in his attic,
which one of the great things,
by the way, about
the book coming out
is that even after
the Anspach case,
like here we are
100 years later.
People are still
finding these things
and now understand where
they're coming from.
But you can see it definitely
has color groupings.
And it says Monopoly just
clean across the top.
So the idea that people weren't
calling it Monopoly, I mean,
this comes up in
the depositions.
But they were calling it that.
A lot of the distinctive
features were there.
So Ralph starts talking
publicly about this history.
And he starts referring
to it as the Monopoly
lie and this corporate scandal
and that Parker Brothers had
erased this woman from history.
And he's very vocal
about this, even
though litigation is going on.
And he learns about this
Atlantic City Monopoly
tournament that's going on.
And they're giving
out the Darrow cup.
And he seethes.
He thinks this is
outrageous, because Darrow
didn't originate the game.
So he decides he's going
to sabotage the tournament.
And this is an ad he takes out.
He's going to have a Truth
about Monopoly lecture
next to where a lot of the press
that was covering the Monopoly
tournament was staying.
So unfortunately,
Parker Brothers
catches wind of this
event, because he had
been advertising it, after all.
And they rearrange the schedule.
So basically nobody comes.
But you wouldn't know by
looking at this photograph.
Ralph looks pretty excited.
But he's undeterred.
There's actually a
bigger tournament
taking place in Washington,
DC, soon thereafter.
Now, because this case had
gotten lot of attention,
he heard from these
two college kids
at Cornell who were part
of the Ivy League Monopoly
Association, which was an
unsanctioned tournament.
And they had also
published a "How
to Win a Monopoly" book that
had rattled a lot of people
at Parker Brothers.
So these college kids
reach out to Ralph and say,
we're in it to win it.
We're with you on this crusade.
We're going to sabotage this DC
Monopoly tournament with you.
So what they do
is they go to DC,
and they slip like Truth
about Monopoly pamphlets
under people's dinner plates,
especially the journalists.
So they're successful.
And everybody starts laughing.
It's great.
So one of those college kids
is Jay Walker, the billionaire
founder of Priceline.com.
And when Ralph originally
told me this story,
I thought Jay Walker is
such an ambiguous name.
So of course I had to
contact him and be like, hey,
I'm fact-checking a story for
"The Wall Street Journal."
Did you, like, sabotage
a Monopoly tournament
when you were in college?
[LAUGHTER]
And Jay was like, oh, yeah.
How's Ralph?
Send him my best.
And it totally check out.
And I was like, that's insane.
And then the other
author of this book--
you can see Jay-- I did
some serious like Amazon
and eBay squatting and finally
got a copy-- is Jeff Lehman.
So Jeff Lehman was his
roommate at Cornell,
who ended up becoming
the president of Cornell
and actually came
to an event I did.
So on the book tour, people
that are in the story
keep showing up.
So it's kind of great.
So when I did this
presentation at NYU,
I was like, that guy
sabotaged the tournament.
So anyway, meanwhile in
court, Parker Brothers
wins an injunction.
And normally when you
win an injunction,
you take whatever merchandise
you're arguing about,
and you like throw it in
a warehouse or something.
But Parker Brothers is so
confident they're going to win,
they decide to stage a
burial of Ralph's 40,000
Anti-Monopoly games.
And they invite journalists.
Like people covered this.
This is a photo of those games
being buried in Minnesota.
And at this point, this battle
has been going on for years.
His personal relationships
are really frayed.
He's gone through
several lawyers.
Litigation wasn't cheap then
as it obviously isn't now.
So his finances-- I think he
had taken out maybe two if not
three mortgages at this point.
He's at his wit's end.
And he thinks he's
winning, actually.
But Parker Brothers decides to
appeal to the Supreme Court.
This is not good.
Ralph's lawyer at
this point was a guy
named Carl Pearson, one-man
legal shop, basically.
And the two of them were
working around the clock.
And the amicus briefs in this
case are really fun to read,
because it's like a who's
who of corporate America.
And the argument was
basically that if you
allow-- I'm really,
really paraphrasing here,
but that trademark law as
we know it will collapse
if you let Anti-Monopoly win.
But the Supreme Court refuses to
hear the case, and Ralph wins.
And he not only wins his
right to make Anti-Monopoly,
but he wins his right to talk
about the history and origins
openly.
And the court
upholds his research
and that the game actually
originated with Lizzie
Magie and these Quaker players.
However, victory is
not enough for Ralph,
and he decides he wants
to go dig up his games.
There's 40,000 of them.
They're in Minnesota.
They're his.
And after all,
he's won the case.
The Supreme Court has
put the final word on it.
So he and his friend
Russ Foster-- this
is a really poor
quality photo of them--
they go to try and dig.
And they look and they
look and they look
and they can't find them.
They're really frustrated.
They pack it in.
Then a friend
contacts him and says,
so, you're digging
in the wrong spot.
And Ralph says, oh,
well, we'll go back.
We'll find them.
And they said, well,
you can't really
do that, because they started
building condos on top
of where they were buried.
[LAUGHTER]
So when sometimes people ask me,
why have you spent five years
researching Monopoly, which is
a perfectly legitimate question,
I feel like sometimes if we
don't-- these games are going
to get found, right?
Whether that's a year
from now or 10 years
or 10,000 years from now.
And we need a
document or something
explaining why they got
there, how they got there.
And as far as I know,
they're still there.
So there you have it.
[LAUGHTER]
So I follow Monopoly
iconography a lot.
And one of the things
that's amazing to me
is that the game is
still everywhere.
It's a meme, which
makes me happy.
It's on "Gossip Girl."
Jon Stewart's a fan.
And I put this tattoo
up there, only because I
want to find this person.
And I feel like if you have an
arm sleeve of Monopoly stuff,
you're going to show up to some
Monopoly-related book event.
If anybody has any intelligence,
please let me know.
I really just curious.
I want to know
everything about it.
So this is my book.
And you can buy millions
of copies of it.
And I feel like, just
to go back to this
why-obsessively-research-games
piece, I think that for me,
this was like a fact-checking
question gone awry.
I, like everybody, thought
Monopoly was invented
during the Great Depression.
And in researching
it, it's taught me
a lot about how things
are actually made.
I think that we love
the light bulb story.
We love the Darrow story
because it's so romantic.
Like who doesn't want
to believe that that
could happen to any of us?
But the truth is that making
things, whether it's a game
or-- I mean, I'm sure you
guys go through this here
all the time.
It's really complicated
and messy and collaborative
and it takes trial and error.
And that's the
story of Monopoly.
So I'm happy to take any
questions you may have.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any pet theories
on what happened in
the patent office,
like for them to forget
or lose the patent?
MARY PILON: Ooh.
So one of the things that's
been so fun about this
has been the book has brought
a lot of conspiracy theorists
out.
And so some people have
offered up theories.
Based on my reporting,
I have none.
Like I have no clue.
And obviously because the
property became so lucrative,
there's a ton of incentive
to get rid of stuff.
But also, with historical
research, one of the things
that blows me away is that any
of the stuff survives at all,
I mean especially
like Lizzie Magie
and some of those documents.
So, people just lost
stuff all the time.
So I have no idea.
I mean, I love the idea of
like a sinister back story.
But the truth is, it could
have been some janitor.
So I have no idea.
But it's a great question.
Do you?
What do you know?
AUDIENCE: I mean, it's the
'30s, it's Parker Brothers.
Any number of sketchy stuff
could happen, especially
considering that you
had a bunch of lefties
at the time championing it.
MARY PILON: Right, right.
Absolutely.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what is the
state of competitive Monopoly
like now?
Are there big
tournaments going on?
MARY PILON: So that's
a great question.
One of my favorite
books is "Work Freak"
by Stefan Fatsis, which if
you haven't read, it's great.
It's about competitive
Scrabble playing.
And I think because of the
nature of Monopoly as a game,
it doesn't have the same
competitive circuit.
Like Hasbro every now and then
will sponsor a tournament.
I think there's one
in Macau this fall.
But it's very all
over the place.
It's not like it
happens every year.
And if you really want to
geek out on the game design,
I think that Monopoly
is not designed to be
as great of a strategic game.
Like you can't study up for it
the same way you can Scrabble.
So there really hasn't been
much of a competitive circuit
And I think that's OK.
I mean, sometimes people
think I'm like this monopoly
purist and a nut.
And I'm like, no, like Settlers
of Catan is a great game.
But like Monopoly was
like from a century ago.
I kind of think of it-- when
I did this event at the Game
Design Center, all these games
designers were like, it sucks.
And I was like, it's like a
Model T. It's OK that it's not
a perfect game today.
It was a great
stepping-off point
for all these other great ones.
So yeah, I mean, one of the
problems with it, too, is it's
a very lopsided game.
So unless you're playing
with people who actually
follow the rules and kind
of have a similar skill
set, like the deal-making and
the stuff that makes it fun,
it kind of falls flat.
But yeah, there's tournaments.
Sorry if that was a
disappointing answer. [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: My dad was actually
the Monopoly champion
of Pennsylvania [INAUDIBLE].
MARY PILON: Woo!
Yeah!
Guys, we have
royalty in the room.
[APPLAUSE]
Who knew?
AUDIENCE: But his family
grew up playing Monopoly.
And they're super competitive.
And you're right.
Like they all play
together and like
I just get destroyed
every single time.
MARY PILON: Right,
right, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: But he
actually went-- they
had a tournament in
New York after he won
the whatever,
Pennsylvania championship.
And then he lost at the I
guess US-wide tournament,
but it's still going on.
[LAUGHS]
MARY PILON: That's awesome.
And there's some unsanctioned
tournaments, too,
the dark underbelly of
competitive Monopoly playing.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about the history
of modern board games.
Was Monopoly very
unprecedented at the time?
Or was there already
a large collection
of other similar
things that people
were playing with
like dice on boards
that weren't checkers or chess?
MARY PILON: Absolutely,
so there's a lot more
about that in the book
and the history of Parker
Brothers and Milton Bradley.
Because I felt like I
need a lot of context,
even walking up to
Lizzie Magie's game.
So when you look at her patent,
there were a lot of things
there that I hadn't seen before,
so like the circular game
design.
What wasn't unique about hers
was that games at the time
were often used for teaching.
They were often used as
a means of communication,
just like you would write
an article about something
political you were fired
up about or what have you.
What was strange
about Monopoly is
that it really, as a commercial
game, was a huge blockbuster.
And it opened the door for
all these other financial
and real estate
games and things.
But there hadn't
really been a game
that had sold quite at that
level and kind of popped
through.
And games that were commercial
hits were rare enough.
But Monopoly was kind of one
of the first marketed games
that is a perennial.
I mean, here we are sitting
around talking about it.
And nobody ever really gotten
rich off of a game like Darrow
had.
So it kind of created
this following.
After Darrow sold the
game, Parker Brothers
started getting
all these pitches
from people wanting to
become the next Darrow.
And I think that was, from
a marketing perspective,
something that hadn't
really happened before.
But the history of games
leading up to this point
is like worthy of a second book.
And there's some in
bibliography that, if you really
want to go in the weeds
on that, might be useful.
I'd be happy to point
then out to you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So people
publish entirely
alternate rule sets for
Monopoly and just throw out
most of the concepts
of the game.
You still use the board.
You still use the pieces.
Do you have a favorite alternate
rules set of that sort?
MARY PILON: So this group
of-- I get really great emails
from people about this.
And this was maybe
a year or two ago.
Somebody had
emailed me, and they
created a version of the
game with securitization.
So like you're
selling properties,
but you're bundling.
You're bundling
mortgages and stuff.
And I thought it was kind of
a fascinating, great idea.
And so you clearly have to
play with a group of players
that are into that.
But I thought that
was very, very funny.
And it was the first
time I had even
thought of securitizing
mortgages and stuff
on the Monopoly board.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In that
regard, what do you
think of like the new version
of Monopoly with credit cards
and like amounts like
the millions of dollars?
MARY PILON: Sure, so I did a
piece for the "Sunday Review"
at "The Times" about this.
As a purist, I think
it's a little silly.
But I also think that it's
a little hypocritical of me
to be like, you can't put
credit cards in Monopoly.
Because if you look at
the origins of the game,
it was all about people
making it their own.
So it's just another
iteration of it.
And one of the things I find
really strange about that
is a parent came up to me at
an event I did and was like,
oh, we use Monopoly to
teach our kids about money.
And I was like, oh, I
guess my parents did, too.
And she was like, no,
you don't understand.
Because of credit cards,
they don't see me use money.
Like they don't understand
$5 versus $10 versus $20.
And I was like, oh, whoa.
So like if you do the credit
card version of the game,
you lose that financial lesson.
So I mean, I don't own it.
I'm also not a game collector.
I mean, I live in New York City.
I don't have time
for that or space.
So I guess I'm kind of meh
about it, to summarize.
I didn't write that in
the "Sunday Review,"
like, Mary's meh about it,
leave the rest of the space.
So, yeah.
Any other questions, comments,
concerns, thought of your day?
AUDIENCE: So can we all start
selling our own derivatives
of the game Monopoly?
MARY PILON: So that's
a very juicy question.
So there's a
collector in Portland.
His website is
landlordsgame.info.
And he's going to start
making Landlord's Games.
And I'm not a lawyer,
but my understanding
is that Hasbro controls the
brand, like the Monopoly brand.
And then all those
spin off games,
USAopoly makes with a
license through Hasbro.
So again, with my non-legal hat,
my guess is you probably could.
But it wouldn't be
surprising-- I mean,
do you want to fight a 10-year
long legal battle like Ralph?
I mean, I don't know.
But he did win.
AUDIENCE: There's
precedent now, right?
MARY PILON: Right, well, also--
and this is in the book, too,
and I didn't include it
here, but after his case,
the trademark lobby
approached Congress,
and they rewrote trademark law.
And they tucked it into I think
it was the Semiconductor Chip
Act.
And it's actually called--
So Ralph's lawyer at the time
had to reach out to-- I
think Orin Hatch sponsored
the amendment but
had to reach out
to whoever's representative
it was at the time.
And there's actually an
Anti-Monopoly amendment,
which is insane.
So like this case, there's
like a hole, and then
this new batch of
trademark law, which
is why I'm a little
hesitant to say it.
Because if you were to
fight Ralph's case today,
it would be a
different legal thing.
Because trademark and patent law
has changed so much, partially
as a result of this case.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So Monopoly
seems to be very centered
in American culture,
and I'm wondering
if you've seen interesting
international versions
of the game?
MARY PILON: Absolutely.
So the first country that I'm
aware of outside of the US
where it was played
was in the UK,
and Waddington's
controlled the license.
So what's weird
is that if you go
to different parts of
the world, they made it--
so if you buy a French
version of the game,
it's going to have
Paris properties.
If you go to London, it's
going to have Piccadilly Circus
and all this other stuff on it.
So yeah, they're huge.
And somebody told
me Brazil, they even
have Sao Paulo and Rio versions.
So those are really popular.
They're everywhere.
And actually, this is really
getting back in the history,
but board games are
interesting politically,
because there's all sorts of
chatter about whether they
were allowed across the Wall.
Was Monopoly allowed?
It's a symbol of capitalism.
And the history
is a little murky.
But one thing I did
find in my research
is that Adolf Hitler used board
games a lot with Hitler youth.
And there are these
really insane games.
Like there's one called Juden
Raus, which means Jews Out.
And seeing really insane
propaganda on board games
was like, wow,
like people really
understood the power of these
as tools and teaching tools.
And so there were
Monopoly spinoffs,
and because this game
was so successful,
a lot of people, good and evil,
started making them worldwide
in all these bizarre,
different flavors.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I remember
reading somewhere
that the game
mechanics of Monopoly
are purposefully terrible
to essentially teach
that Monopoly, like
the real-life concept,
is not fun, because one person
ends up with everything,
and everybody else
is just kind of
crushed beneath the
machine of capitalism.
[LAUGHTER]
Is there any truth to that?
MARY PILON: So what's
funny about that
is that when Lizzie
Magie made her 1904 game,
she made two rule sets.
She made a monopolist rule set
and an anti-monopolist rule
set.
And the monopolist rule set
is the one that takes off.
So you can read into
human nature whatever
you want on that, that we
chose the evil one where
we have to crush everybody.
So I think you could
make an argument, right?
Like her politics were
clear, like she did not
think that-- her
view of capitalism
was not that one person
should control everything,
you have to destroy
everybody else.
So you could make this argument
that the monopolist rule
set and its origins
was to teach people
about how awful it feels to lose
at Monopoly, which, we've all
been there.
So I don't think
that's off base.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: My son is
super into Monopoly.
He has like the Batman
Monopoly, the Yankees Monopoly.
Do you have a
favorite alternative?
MARY PILON: Your
son has good taste.
Let me think about that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARY PILON: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: I'm sure you've
seen all the variations?
MARY PILON: I've
see a lot of them.
It's kind of impossible
to see them all.
I like them all.
But I actually-- this
is going to sound
really geeky, but recently
through a game designer,
I was able to play the
Quaker version right
before the auctions were added.
So if you play Monopoly
where you land on every-- you
could probably do it with your
son at home, where every time
you land on a property,
you auction it.
It changes the entire game.
But it changes it in a way
that I think is kind of fun
if you're used to
playing the game.
So I think like the
pre-Parker Brothers auction
Monopoly is my new favorite.
In terms of the
commercially sold one,
I grew up in Eugene, Oregon, so
Duckopoly was a family default
if we didn't play the
traditional, which
is hyper-local, because
Eugene is not big place.
It's like, oh, that's our
street, which was always fun.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Did you have any
interactions with Parker
Brothers during your research?
MARY PILON: So, yes.
I contacted them
several times, sent them
hundreds of
fact-checking questions.
When the excerpt ran in the
"Times" a few weeks ago,
I contacted them again.
They have not like
offered anybody up
for interviews, no
comment, anything
like that, which isn't the first
time a journalist has received
a no.
Although they acquired the
company in the early '90s,
so the bulk of this story
took place before then.
And because of this court
case, I had a lot of documents.
So whenever possible, like
Barton, his deposition
is a whole sequence in the book.
I tried to give voice.
Because I was really interested
in the history of this company.
And I was really interested
in the decisions they made.
And I think it's really
easy to write a story that's
black and white, but actually,
this one had a lot of gray.
And I was able to talk a
lot of former executives
and former people and
people in the family who
are related to it.
So I feel like I was
still able to get--
I tried my darndest to get as
full if a picture as I could.
But yeah, it's always
a bummer when somebody
doesn't want to talk to you.
Any other questions?
I think I've heard every
Monopoly-related question
at this point.
I've heard every Monopoly pun.
Yes, I've passed go, all that.
AUDIENCE: What's your strategy
when you play Monopoly?
Do you have a strategy?
MARY PILON: So the Jay
Walker book that I mentioned
is actually, if you want a pure
strategy book, pretty great.
I am a big believer of the strip
between Jail and Free Parking,
because it gets landed on more.
And the ROI if you're
building is pretty great.
And I'm a big advocate
of housing shortages.
So what most people
don't realize
is that the number of houses
and hotels in any game is fixed.
So what I do is I become
like a total slum lord.
And I don't think I've
bought a hotel in Monopoly
in like years.
It's just like not interesting.
And it totally screws people,
and they don't realize it
until it's too late.
I don't think I've purchased
Free Parking or North Carolina
Avenue or any of the greens or
any of those in a long time,
either, unless you're trying
to thwart a competitor.
But there you have it.
Too expensive to
build-- not interested.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARY PILON: Right.
No, but most people--
who here has actually
ever read the Monopoly rules?
OK, this is a smart room.
Because like in
my family, people
will argue with me about it.
I'm like, right, Dad, what
do I know about Monopoly?
You're right, we
should put everything
in Free Parking-- no.
It's still a source
of-- still a raw nerve.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Have you
met Ralph in person?
MARY PILON: Yeah, I spent a
lot of time interviewing him.
AUDIENCE: So how is he?
What was he like?
MARY PILON: Ralph
is really funny.
He's 89.
And actually, I just
emailed him a few weeks ago
about something.
And he said something amazing,
which is life begins at 89.
[LAUGHTER]
And I was like, wow,
that's an amazing insight.
Because like, poor Ralph--
like I started interviewing him
five years ago.
And as far as I know, this is
the first journalistic account
of the whole history.
So to wait 40 years for a
journalist to come along,
or 34 years or whatever,
that's a long time to wait.
And I interviewed his sons.
And his ex-wife actually passed
away while I was reporting.
She was really helpful.
So I kind of got
this portrait of him
not just from spending time
with him but also his family.
He's very professorial.
And the fact that this story
fell in the hands of somebody
who had a PhD in
economics was, I think,
one of the great
things that happened.
Because he basically
became a paralegal
and understood
the inner workings
of this case and the history
and the politics of it in a way
that, had it been somebody
who just made a board
game or something, I
don't think the story
would have been as fleshed out.
But he's very academic,
very even-tempered.
One of things I
struggled with a lot
in writing it is I
kept asking myself-- he
turned down a massive
settlement offer.
And there's a lot more drama
in the book about what it
took for him to win this case.
And I thought, God, me
and most people I know
would have called it quits.
And also, we knew the outcome.
When you're doing
historical research,
you're looking at it knowing
that he'd already won.
And he obviously didn't, because
this was happening in real time
and he had so many
odds against him.
And I was like, why
did he fight this?
And his background
is that he was
born in Danzig, Jewish
family, fled to the States.
Had he stayed any longer,
he probably would have died.
And then he was an immigrant
in the United States.
So understanding his
history as a fighter,
as somebody who had
to battle to survive,
made me understand why
he was in the Bay Area
also protesting against
the Vietnam War.
And I think one of
his sons told me
that he would go
to these marches
with like a helmet,
like that takes
a certain kind of personality.
And it took me a long
time to kind of reconcile
this gentle old man
with his sweaters
and mismatched shirts with that.
And I think that
that's a challenge
that you have in more
historical reporting
that you don't in journalism.
When you report
like a daily story,
the person is right
there and you're
watching them do the thing that
is putting them in the news.
And with this, I had wind
back the clock a lot more.
Because he had evolved a
lot as a result of this,
too, even from the start
of the case to the end.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: We all know how
most of the house rules
make the game way worse.
But have you run
across any house
rules that make it way better?
MARY PILON: The one
that comes to mind just
off the top my head
is playing it timed,
just because it kind of
incentivizes people, kind
of like you would with chess.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARY PILON: Yeah.
my family won't do it that way.
But that seems like a fun way.
And also, there's ways you
can start with handing out
people's properties.
So you just start
where everybody-- it
makes the game go faster, too.
But you just have to work with
what you're handed, basically.
So it's kind of like Clue
where you hand out the-- you
have whatever evidence
you have in the beginning.
So that's another one
that I think is fun.
It's good with kids, too.
Yes?
Anything else?
I was so nervous.
I was like, God, everybody
at Google is so smart.
And somebody at
Bloomsbury was like, you
know a lot about Monopoly.
It's gonna be OK.
[LAUGHS] I was like,
they could probably have a
Monopoly division at Google,
and we wouldn't even know.
[LAUGHTER]
They could be making
the sets downstairs.
We can't make any assumptions.
Any other questions?
Great-- thank you so much.
And if you have any
questions, email me.
[APPLAUSE]
That's not a dummy Gmail.
I actually use it.